Oh
There I am I did that for like eight times, you know this this fight scene definitely had people talking
Thanks to today's sponsors Squarespace stay tuned to the end of the episode to learn how to get 10% off your first purchase of a
Website or domain
Guys, welcome back to another episode of stuntman. React ski dude. It's so good to see you again, man
Yes been so long. I miss you man. I miss you. Hopefully yo yo, what's up guys? My name is jii the Silva green
I am a professional stunt man who is known for his work in Captain America Civil War along with some other cool stuff
There have many productions of the pastor there has been nothing. I finally get to see daylight
Yeah, we're gonna hop into some clips here like I got a lot of fun stuff prepped for you guys today
Let's get started with one of my favorite kung fu movies of all time.IP man, just clarify. It's not like Superman
It's his last names like Mon, right? Yeah
This was a story about a real guy was a guy who trained Bruce Lee this was choreographed by Sima hyung, right?
Yeah, really? So if you guys know same Oh hyung he's one of the three dragons, right?
You got Jackie Chan say mo hyung and you'd be out they all went to the same, you know scroll together with their head
Yeah, so same o hyung. He's the one who choreographed this whole movie. He's in it man two nephews
I'm a huge fan of his choreography style. It's very clean. It's very deliberate. You can see what's going on in the way
It's shot and covered is it's impeccable in my opinion
We got an intro fight one of the bad guys rolling into town and he's gonna beat up all of the kung-fu masters
So challenging different styles like my Styles better than your style. Yeah. Oh, yeah. Why can't we live in a world like that?
I want to live in a town where it's like just martial arts schools or literally right across the street from each other. Yeah
Challenge you yeah, I'll be so happy. That's I hope heavens like that
The bounce-back, that's my favorite my favorite
Whole fight sequence. Is that right? There? He bounced them like a ball right there. Yeah. Yeah, so that's Wireless
That's like sneaky wires, right? Yes, it is
one of the best people to show
That sneaky style of wire work is Jackie Chan in all of his like old 80s stuff like they use it just to amplify
Just enough
Like they'll they'll tag a leg and it's when it's swept they pull the leg even harder just to make it look even more
Violent and I think that's so fun
Do you love the closer to like the just the feet like hitting faces
I've heard that very frequently when they're doing shots like that
It's just somebody's arm in a pant leg on the hand. We do that all the time and
Very funny, especially if you don't have an extra pair of pants
Guy just said no no pants on buddy. Well, he does have pants on they're
The same mo trick is that he likes to use those close-ups that were they he can break a 180 at times
Hey, what do you mean by brick the 180 and jump the line?
So there's certain rules in film that you're supposed to not break. There's a rule about
Breaking the line or the 180 where they stay they're staying on the outside, right?
So like if me and gear fighting right now
We draw a line with our bodies between us you're on one side of the line. Nico's on the other side of the line
So as we're fighting if you were to move the camera
Over to Nico side and Nico's filming us that's 180 degree move. We had to jump the line. You're like, whoa
Wait, I just teleported. Yes. Now you have motion sickness and you're confused
You you can't follow the rhythm of the fight, but they broke the line in this fight. And why did it work?
They go really tight and show like a fist making connection
You can jump the line on those close-ups because you you're out of context
It just a close-up on one guy at the fist coming. Yeah
Dude my my buddy Marcus his cousin they don't a sound design studio and they did the sound design for this whole movie. What?
Yeah, that's really cool Hong Kong
Yeah sound design can make or break a fight without a doubt when you're doing with hips
Whether it's gunshots bullet hits punches things like that. That sound only lasts for a frame
You know twenty-fourth of a second what gives it power is its tail and its heads so, you know
The lead-in is going to give you that wind up. It's it's the breath you take before like the shark attacks, you know
You know that sets you up for how intense that hits going to be
So back in the day when I started doing fight scenes
Yeah, I was like, oh cool. I should do woosh noises before my punch noises, you know
Yeah pop and it always sounded really bad
What I was doing wrong is I just using air whooshes and said we need is the cloth yes
Sound like your sleeve everything's like sliding against your skin until that that plays intact. You need that clock
we did that punch for that punch to have because otherwise he just had a little
And that that's that's nothing, you know, like that doesn't sound powerful. But if you have a
Cool, you know that all those sound effects stacked on top you give that sound that single punch a story and say a set up
In a payoff, you know
like this thing's coming in quick and you get popped and then it's the repercussion of that the sound design is there to tell a
Story, yes, and then there's also like what type of universe are you in? Because then the sounds are different. Yeah
I said matrix has a completely different sound than the John wick
Fun fact for the punch sounds in the matrix, they hit turkeys with baseball bats not live turkeys
I want to show you one more fight from it man
They basically moot they come in and they force them to fight the Japanese
have a little mini tournament to show off their power and it man's friends they start dying and
It means like I gotta go see for myself what's going on? He's not having it any more
And so good the - yeah, this dis fight scene, I think definitely had people talking
This was like pre-raid and this is what everybody was talking about pre-raid
Know he really stepped up. You've really stepped on him for sure. Yeah, that's a stomp
You know Donnie was really hurting people in this that was hearing stories from some of my friends that they were saying again like Donnie
He'll be like hey
I'll give you an extra couple hundred dollars if you let me knock you out and
When it comes to being a stunt man in China if you're not on camera
You don't get paid at all. So you could be sitting there all day in costume waiting and not get shot. And now you are
Not getting paid for that day. You just said it rather than hung out
I just want to be the guy in the background. Just holding a christ dance the whole time. I got them guys
I got him look see
Oh
So Donnie answers like I'll give you $100
She's a really flexible dude or doesn't dude without a leg. No, it's it there's definitely a fake leg in the pants because
His leg. Oh, yeah. You're right. He's just
Crazy, yeah, you don't notice at all in motion. It works
Machine gun blows
Dude he's like his head is bouncing like I'm freaking speed
Man, he's definitely making contact. Oh good
Maybe he's using hollow fist
So there's like so we make a fist and then we put our thumb through and then you have a hole
Yeah, and then you can it still looks like a fifth
Yeah, but there's there's enough give that you know, I mean, it's not gonna feel good regardless
I
Love it when they actually commit to having four guys attack at once
it's so hard to choreograph and stuff it is so I mean in reality is like how do you fight four guys at once like
Well, you get hit
Right here
Like yes
That's that's good timing by the stunt guys and the actor who's performing it because it's done in
Donnie Yen is using both arms and his leg at the same time to fight. Yeah, all these dudes Wow. Yeah, that's cool
Shots of Sam. Oh, yeah. Yeah, seriously just this movie's solid all the way around from the choreography to the story
That's why he can make four. Oh my god. They just got worse. They got so bad. I saw three and I was like guy
The Mike Tyson, yeah, what are you guys like?
You see how Tyson looks right now, he's jacked in he's boxing again reminder that coming after you that's 53 years old
He's 53
Do you guys have a scene with some crazy stunts that you would love to see a stunt man break down for you or some?
Woman, please leave a comment down below if there's a son matter stunt woman you would love to have in the show
Give us some suggestions. Well reach out to them
if there's a stunt man or some woman that you know
This is the finale - Lucifer season 4, which I got to work on thanks to Vlad rim burg
He's the choreographer fight coordinator for the show
What is going on there
That's intense like so he sets up for a cheat and then he just opens himself up and then just gets a push kick
No wires, no wires. Dad. Got a real kick there. Yeah, you got a really good
You got get really hit Andrew Franklin taking it like a man and oh damn
It's good air wareness - because he's spinning and he has to open himself up at the right time in order to get hit
Properly so that way he can hit the ground correctly
There there I am looking like I'm supposed to be like kind of dead but not dead
Dude this guy with his double blocks was incredibly so dude. So karate. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah
I
Did that for like eight times Oh, sometimes they they wanted Tom Ellis to be a little bit closer
So I ended up having to do it multiple times then you had like the Gator back
No, I didn't I didn't have a gator back like you said. Yeah, I just was taking it landing on my back
I've done it so many times that I kind of can
just control myself to the point where I'm a hit where I want to hit Tom Ellis does the thing where he
Double claps my ears. He was really clapping. My ears really do like that's like
just ah
Gotten of course, everybody's laughing at me while this is happening because they know I'm in pain that'll actually like cause some serious damage
Yeah, absolutely. So be careful when you guys do that. Don't aim at the ears go either. I would say behind the ears
I won't even think they made it in the cut and that's what hurts so much you do all this work and
It's it gets cut out sometimes because it doesn't fit pacing or they need to cut time for the film for
Whatever it is that they're trying to do, right?
That baby Johnston really yeah
Everybody we know pretty much it looks like it was cheated a little bit here with this cut right there
Yeah, but it actually flows getting it like you still have that
Rotational movement that was really nice into the next shot. So and then she just gets destroyed because the vertical power punch. Yeah
That's such a cool move dude like throwing weapons, yeah, that's actually
Shad gaspard. He's a former WBE superstar from crime the group crime time
He actually recently just passed away. He was in the ocean at Venice Beach and
The riptides got him and he saved his son
No way man is so rough shad gaspard art, man, big bro. Rest in peace, man
So I got I got one last clip for you guys I want to bring it all the way back to
1973. Oh, yeah. It's actually the year Bruce Lee passed away. This is his last complete movie. We're talking about Enter the Dragon guys Oh
Boom I love the fake-out you don't see that a lot anymore. I know like that's a true strategy in fighting
What was his plan there I don't know what his plan I don't know
Maybe he was going for the dragon. Kick the flying side. Kick it he's like, I'm not gonna get my leg cut
So I'll just take it across the ABS cuz there's steel here it comes. Imma go again
And that looked like an actual foot I think that was a foot oh, you know who choreographed this Sam. Oh no
He was the coordinator on this what yeah, are you serious? Yeah, he's in though. He's the opening fight. That's Sam. I hope
You didn't know that
The EM yo is the acrobatic double for Bruce. No way cuz I know Jackie Chan's in this
Yeah, they're all in it because of Sam Oh Sam
I was the one who brought them all into stunts and this is one of the first films that they all worked on that's freaking
awesome
You know this kick though
Yeah that dog
That the dude is dead
That is a car crash right there. It scares me how powerful that is
There was barely any hit turn in that kick too, which makes it even more scarier
most people when they kick through they they take from the muy Thai and
It goes all the way across
So most of the time you'll end up throwing a round cake and you'll spin all the way back around 360
His his hips go at most 40 foot like it's there and then it comes right back
So he's he's fighting it and bringing it all the way back at the end of that instead
Just letting it flow all the way through. So he keeps himself in camera in frame. You see its face the whole time
So to have that much power while also then applying the brakes right so much control Mans. That's AB work pure core
That makes that possible. Well, I mean Bruce Lee is just entirely a core. Yeah, he's just ABS
This is technically what would happen today?
If Dana White created fight island
Which is literally the start of how hot why hi-yah is where Han is yeah you guys this island?
No guns allowed their only martial artist. I was like heaven. That's the edge of the Dragon remake. Yeah, five islands Korea by the UFC
Hey guys
I'm out here training again working on my next stunt real because after the last ones that I did on the stuntmen reacts videos
I booked a gig that's right now granted it was for my uncle's car dealership
but it doesn't really matter because I still booked a gig this whole endeavor was made possible because of my Squarespace page and I'm gonna
Show you how if you guys are interested in starting a new endeavor this year
I mean 2020 what the heck Squarespace is the perfect thing to get you started
So I'm out here to Train again and to do another stun reel to make a good stunt reel
You don't need to go to a gym
All you need is a nice open field and a beautiful tree much like Squarespace is beautiful award-winning templates
Now this tree overhangs the field and from it
You can see everything much like squarespace's traffic overviews tools, which allow you to see who comes to your site
Squarespace is multiple contributors tools
You can give different people different levels of access on your site depending on who they are and what their needs are
Squarespace is simultaneous posting tool
You can delete frog over the painstaking process of posting the same thing on
multiple social media plan
Once you post it one time on your website through Squarespace and it automatically formats and goes out to your other social media profiles
That's real great
of course baits also has an audio blocks feature that allows you to post podcasts on your site and
Automatically serve as an RSS feed going out on all podcast distribution platforms. Oh, yeah
Well, I think that's about enough content for my next stunt reel
But if you guys are interested in starting a new endeavor of your own make it twenty20 make it
Squarespace because god only knows what's gonna happen the rest of this year
But one thing's for sure you can get 10% off your first purchase of a website or domain by going to Squarespace
Calm and such code or crew. That's Squarespace calm
corridor and grill
Guys, thank you so much for sticking around and joining us Keith
It was an amazing to have you on the dude follow me on
Instagram if you have not yet some awesome stuff asking some questions. Maybe he'll respond who
I
Tried to man. I'm asked the same question over and over again. How do you become a stunt man?
How do you begin with something?
I would say the best thing to do is find into the closest area a hub Atlanta, New York, Los Angeles
Go to the gyms that have open gym try to move some people
There's a whole bunch of people online
that are
Around you can try to see if you can go whether where they train or where they work out start working on your phones
There's a bunch of videos online that show you the basic falls
The first couple jobs are going to do is going to be throwing a right hook
Missing gang punch in the face. Ouch that hurt and then you're hanging the ground
So get good at doing those three things and more than likely you start working your way towards being a stunt person
Thank you guys for watching you guys have cool clips, please
Leave a comment down below also subscribe if you're not and stick around guys
Cuz we got videos like this coming out every single week. So I'll see you guys next time